[Music]
We are back on Dead Doctors Don't Lie
filling in for Dr. Joel Wallik. Today
we've got Dr. Peter Glidden. Welcome
back, Dr. Glidden. Hey, hey, hey. Thanks
a lot, Doug. Who's calling first? All
right, let's head to Minnesota. And
Oxanna, you are on with Dr. Peter
Glidden.
Yes. Hello. Hello, Oxanna. Thanks for
calling. How can I help? Yes. Um I have
a rheumatoid arthritis for um 15 years
and I was on several medications and now
they switch me to a new one. For about
the 3 months I'm on actra infusions and
they don't help me and even worse they I
have so many side effects. I start this
uh yanje um supplements about two weeks
ago. I really like the taste and I feel
a little bit better like with my energy.
But um I just wanted to know uh if
people really get results with
rheumatoid arthritis which is very
severe in my case. Oh yeah, absolutely.
And but you have to understand one
thing. It's a million times easier to
paint over the mold that's in the
basement than it is to actually fix the
mold that's in the basement. Right? Uh
so healing with uh science-based
clinically verified medical nutrition,
which is what you're doing. The
longevity program that you're uh doing
is intending to support and promote your
body's ability to fix itself. That's the
intention here. It's to make it easier
for your body to fix the joints. It's to
make it easy for your body to optimize
its joint function. Now listen, you've
been dealing with this for a long, long
time. It's not going to go away in two
weeks. Healing is easy, but healing is a
process, not an event. Healing is
something that unfolds itself over time.
You know, you wouldn't put a tomato seed
in the ground on Monday and expect to be
eating a tomato on Friday, right? It
takes a while for that plant to grow and
mature and ripen and everything has to
be just right. Healing here, Roxanna, is
a function of time. The most important
thing now in the first two, three, four
weeks, the majority of people who get on
board with the longevity program, they
feel a positive difference somewhere.
And that's the most important thing that
in the first couple of weeks, we feel a
positive change somewhere, which you've
already done with your energy. Now what
that means is that you're on the right
track and all that you need to do here
is just maintain the discipline, keep
taking the supplements. Uh keep
following the diet. There are two things
that you have to do here. You have to
eliminate the 10 bad foods. You have to
stop eating 10 foods and you have to
consistently take the correct
nutritional supplements appropriate for
your body weight every day. And as you
do this over time, things are going to
get a little bit better, a little bit
better, a little bit better, a little
bit better, a little bit better, and
then boom, all of a sudden, there's
going to be a remarkably fast
improvement. It's kind of like watching
a jumbo jet take off on the runway. It
takes a long time for the nose even to
lift off, and then all of a sudden, 10
seconds later, boom, it's 3,000 ft in
the air. That's what healing with
medical nutrition is like. So maintain
the discipline. You've already
experienced the positive benefits. That
means you're on the right track. Just
keep doing it, baby, and eliminate the
10 bad foods into the bargain. And to
get that list for free, please visit my
website,
fireyourmdow.com, and sign up for the
free monthly newsletter. It's right
there on the front page. And when you
sign up for my free monthly newsletter,
we'll send you the list of the good
food, bad food, eliminate all 10 of the
bad foods. Take your nutritional
supplements and just give it more time.